so people are all over the place with
porn there's a you know a lot of
theories and studies saying porn is
addictive it's bad for you it causes men
to sexualize women and be more
aggressive etc etc but now there's a
couple studies coming out that's saying
that's not quite the case let's look at
some numbers got a big numbers show
today who watches porn ninety percent of
fifteen to twenty five-year-old boys
have admitted to using pornography which
I thought was an interesting word
they're using it not watching it that's
something
forty percent of fifteen to twenty
five-year-old girls have admitted it and
then there's a huge generational divide
which doesn't surprise anyone at 19
percent of people 55 and older said porn
was morally acceptable which seems
pretty low 40 percent of people 18 to 34
said that it was acceptable so is this
is this just a computer thing is this
just an online computer thing because we
all have laptops you got a computer in
your bedroom and a computer and and porn
is just there all the time versus the
80s let's say where you had to buy a
magazine yeah cuz now then you realize
how it's not a big deal you know when we
were growing up the only porn you know
as a kid is the little channels I had
all the fuzz and everything and you
would just see little glimpses of things
you know that's what we would you know
watch now it's just so free and you felt
so bad if you were it was preach to you
that porn is bad it leads to bad bad
things is a gateway drug to everything
else now we've got to the point and this
is the information age where we realize
it's not wrong with it's actually great
to do that and get that out of your
system and it is safer than having real
sex yeah they would warn this like he's
a gateway drug to having real sex it
sounds like a pretty good drug to me
right so I'm shocked by two numbers of
they you showed there for only 40
percent of 18 to 34 year-olds find it
morally acceptable right the else
is the 60 percent thinking crazy where
the young people have morals where did
that come from
right I don't but like I guess I grew up
on porn okay like so to me the idea that
porn is morally unacceptable I find
unfathomable
like what what are you from 18:55 who
thinks that yeah right but apparently a
lot of people do or at least they
pretend to because if you look at the
other number well ninety percent are
doing that morally unacceptable thing so
perhaps you think it's a little
acceptable when you're alone and those
are the people who just admitted it
right exactly so of course these things
aren't purely scientific polls because
people get embarrassed about sexting and
things like that now obviously I have no
personal problem with porn I've watched
too much porn in my life I'm sure of
that
but to play the devil's advocate here
for a second do you think that any of
this stuff whether it's gay porn or
straight porn that it can create like a
constant view of sex that is not real
most of us don't look like those people
they're doing things that positions that
we often can't get into and you know it
doesn't have any is there any negativity
to it I mean are you saying like if it
desensitizes what you and maybe it does
or maybe you find out more about your
body before you get into those
relationships and get married I think
it's crazy that people wait for marriage
to have sex for the first time you can
be miserable like that's a huge part of
a relationship so I think given a test
run is so technical you you get married
in this state so I well sorry I can't
get married but you know I think you
should know your body you should
test-drive everything before you let
someone else get out of it so that's
what I've been doing this whole time
test right yes so look I think that
there is some truth to that I remember
when I was younger and and I'd watch
porn and then I step out into the real
world and there would be like a
buffering time of like three minutes
five minutes where I where I look at
girls and be like are they like like are
they into it is this gonna happen and
I'm like no no what am I thinking this
is the real world of course that's not
gonna happen
yeah so I get that but on the other hand
we buffer okay and then we readjust
unless you're mental you know that
people don't just come up to each other
and go hey you know oh thank you for
fixing my TV now let's you know have sex
immediately yeah well but triple flip
side is it 40
percent of women are watching when I was
growing up I would have been shocked if
the number was 4% because we had to go
find the porn right as Lance was saying
you had to go get a magazine or you had
to get a VHS thing and you had to put it
in there the family TV and so oh not
almost none of the women the girls that
we grew up with we're watching porn and
since they're watching it maybe they are
a little bit more likely to be like okay
I mean you know with this than that than
this right so that does you know women
are not as visual as men are so they
might not be as disappointed as we're
and and we're guys we're guys too so I
think we'll be able to handle anything
right I think the other part of this is
that porn has changed a tremendous
amount so instead of you know somewhat
produced movies with you know overly
tanned and big boobed
whatever that now it's basically like
xtube is like the biggest thing online
which is homemade people doing this up
and they're actually monetizing it - did
you ever think when you were stealing
those VHS tapes and doing whatever you
had to do that basically everyone was
gonna have a webcam in their room and
you can be a you're a porn actor like
that if you want to be well everybody
wants to be a porn actor now I mean look
you look at Kim Kardashian and Paris
Hilton I mean they got so famous so rich
how do they break through in the
beginning home made a sex tape you know
and I mean I guess that's X - right so
they've become in a sense a role model
for the new generation and I got bad
news for a lot of the girls doing that
you're not gonna get rich and famous
in fact you said it's gonna be possibly
deeply embarrassing later I just keep
thinking for all those homemade things
like half the people in your wedding are
gonna have seen it you know don't do it
you know what one day we're gonna have a
president and we'll all have seen his
penis and it'll just be and that'll be
that and at the White House
Correspondents Dinner I make a joke
about like all right we brought a full
circle well done bank Lance I thank you
guys and we do this every week so please
join us again oh and subscribe it's up
there over here or there it's it's
somewhere around here
we'll see you next time thanks I want to
remind you guys that the official
outfitter of the Reuben report is
bonobos go to bonobos com use code TR
r20 and get yourself this fancy shirt